hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar an overview of primary immune
deficiency disorder PID and laboratory
testing for PID I'm Alexis Clouse of
laggards and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by binding site to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor in the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send or answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
and after them today's speaker dr.
Vijaya tonight associate professor
department of pediatrics the University
of Colorado School of Medicine and
Colorado Children's Hospital dr. Knight
graduated from Mysore Medical College
University of Mysore India followed by a
residency in neuro microbiology and
immunology the National Institutes for
mental health and neurosciences India
she obtained a PhD in immunology from
melbourne university australia followed
by three years of postdoctoral work at
the University of California San
Francisco studying immunization by M
tuberculosis and human macrophages she
then spent two years as a Juvenile
Diabetes Research Foundation fellow at
UCSF working on t-cell regulation in
models of autoimmune disease dr. Knight
ven transitions in the biotechnology
industry and spent a couple of years as
a translational research scientist and
was involved in biomarker discovery and
development and immune monitoring for
clinical trials
dr. Knight has for the past ten years
directed the diagnostic immunology and
flow cytometry laboratory at the
National Jewish Health and is currently
heading up diagnostic and translational
immunology of Children's Hospital
Colorado for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Knight you
may now begin your presentation Thank
You Alexis
and thank you to lab roots and for by
anti-bonding site for hosting this
educational section on primary
immunodeficiency and laboratory testing
so the objectives of this seminar are to
provide some definitions around primary
immunodeficiency the current
classification for primary
immunodeficiency we'll talk about the
laboratory diagnostic methods that are
broadly used for primary
immunodeficiency disorders and I will go
through some examples of laboratory
analyses for specific immune
deficiencies so what is primary
immunodeficiency it's generally defined
as a defect of the immune system
resulting from a mutation in a single
gene and this may be inherited or
sometimes could be a de novo mutation
indicating that it may arise later in
life these mutations may compromise
development or function of a component
of the immune system primary
immunodeficiency results in increased
susceptibility to infections but may
also present as autoimmunity increase
inflammation and in some cases increase
susceptibility to certain forms of
cancer a hallmark of primary
immunodeficiency is Recker ined
persistent and difficult to treat
infections and when a patient presents
with these difficult infections it
should prompt the clinician to think
about primary immunodeficiency and
investigate regardless of the age of the
patient
so let's take a quick overview of the
immune system the immune the cells of
the immune system all start from a
hematopoietic progenitor cell or a
hemopoietic precursor as shown in this
figure in the bone marrow
now during development the precursor
cells can take one of two paths they may
take the path of the lymphoid progenitor
which then results in the development of
B cells and T cells as well as natural
killer cells or they may take the
pathway of a common myeloid progenitor
which gives rise to cells with myeloid
origin monocyte and the granulocytes
now when we take a look at B cells B
cells are antibody producing cells and
they may either develop into plasma
blasts which are otherwise known as the
antibody Factory and actually produce
antibodies that we find in circulation
or immunoglobulins or they may develop
into long lasting memory B cells which
can recall a response to a previously
encountered infection or an antigen T
cells may develop commonly into helper T
cells or cd4 T cells or cytotoxic T
cells cd8 T cells of course this is a
rather simplistic picture of development
of the immune system T cells have many
many more subsets as do b-cells but
these are the major subsets we often
consider when starting an initial wake
workup for immune deficiency on the
myeloid side of development the cells
may develop into monocytes which can
then develop into macrophages or
dendritic cells now these two particular
cells are very important for innate
immune responses or once a pathogen is
encountered to be able to engulf it
and presented to T and B cells in order
to stimulate a memory response the
myeloid progenitor may also develop into
the granular site family of immune cells
that includes the neutrophil which is
commonly the first line of defense
against bacterial and fungal infection
the eosinophil which is commonly found
to have a role in infections to
parasites the base of fill and the mast
cell which are important mostly in
allergic responses so given the
complexity of development of the immune
system
a genetic defect anywhere in this
pathway can result in either lack of
development of a particular cell type or
affect the function of one or more of
these subsets looking at the pathway of
development it's easy to note that genes
that are involved in the progenitor
stage can involve multiple cell types
where as genes that are specific to a
t-cell or B cells if mutations occur in
these genes then those particular
subsets may be affected and again the
genes in the earlier part of development
may result in a lack of these cell types
in the periphery whereas genes involved
in the later part of development as in
differentiation of the T cell into cd4
or cd8 may result in a functional
impairment of these cells
so how does immune-deficiency present
now the Jeffrey model foundation that
has been involved in advocacy for
primary immunodeficiency has these
posters that are that you may find when
traveling around the country and doctors
offices and they are used very heavily
to educate patients on the signs of
immune deficiency so let's take a look
at the ten signs of immune deficiency
the 10th
sorry clinical signs and symptoms that
should point towards immune deficiency
from the poster on the left-hand side of
the slide we see that if the patient
presents with four or more new year
infections within a year two or more
serious sinus infections within a year
two or more months on antibiotics with
little effect two or more pneumonias
within a year a failure of an infant to
gain weight or to grow normally
recomment deep skin or organ abscesses
persistent thrush which is Candida
infection in the mouth or fungal
infection on the skin the need for
intravenous antibiotics to clear
infections or two or more deep-seated
infections including septicemia and also
a family history of primary
immunodeficiency so patients presenting
with any of these warning signs would
warrant further investigation into their
immune system to determine if there are
any abnormalities that might point
towards primary immunodeficiency the
poster on the right presents this
information in a more child-friendly
manner because as we are aware primary
immunodeficiency we tend to find quite
commonly in pediatric patients so the
same information is presented in a
series of cartoons making it easier to
explain them to our pediatric patients
now having said that primary
immunodeficiency manifest in the
pediatric age group it's always been
considered that these are fairly rare
immune deficiencies these are fairly
rare clinical conditions however over
the course of the years we have found
that primary immunodeficiency is
probably more common than previously
thought so this slide is taken from a
paper published in 2014 and it shows the
ten year trend of patients that were
followed in clinics that were identified
with primary immunodeficiencies patients
who were referred to centers where
patients with immune deficiencies are
treated or patients receiving
intravenous immunoglobulin and as you
can see here in all of the graphs in
2004 these numbers were fairly low in
the 5,000 and as you can see over the
years there are certainly larger numbers
of patients who are being treated
identified and followed and it's not
because the incidence of primary
immunodeficiency is increasing it's
because we have better tools to
recognize them both clinically and
within the laboratory so the little
cartoon that you see up here on the
right that says think zebra which has
been used by the immune deficiency
foundation is really to say you know
formerly in medical school we're all
taught that when you hear hoofbeats
think of horses or think of the most
common clinical condition the likeliest
possibility however for immune
deficiency it's important to say well
when you see a patient with chronic
infections perhaps we should be thinking
of zebras think about immune deficiency
disorders that though they may be rare
are being recognized increasingly just
because we are now have we now have a
better sense of
volcanium deficiency and laboratory
tools for diagnosis
so the clinical presentation of
immune-deficiency can be variable we
just discussed the fact that patients
often present with multiple infections
difficult to treat infections however
the clinical presentation can be
variable now in the case of chronic
granulomatous disease that we will
discuss a little later in this
presentation this is a disorder of the
neutrophil population specifically and
can be inherited in an x-linked manner
which means it presents mainly in baby
boys so in a clinical presentation of
this sort where baby boys soon after
birth presents with serious bacterial
infections it may be easier for the
clinician to say well let's look at
neutrophil defects since it's pointing
us that way common variable
immunodeficiency on the other hand is a
very heterogeneous presentation it can
present at any age patients may present
with recurrent infections they can
present with chronic lung disease with
gastrointestinal disease autoimmune
disease or even increased incidence of
lymphoma so cvid or common variable
immunodeficiency sometimes thought of as
a catch-all bucket for immune deficiency
and the presentation can be highly
variable autosomal recessive chronic
granulomatous disease doesn't follow the
pattern of x-linked chronic
granulomatous disease it may present in
males or females and may present later
in life with milder infections and
finally even though we consider primary
immunodeficiency to present mainly as
infections we're now aware that the
clinical presentation may be autoimmune
rather than infectious
so given this wide variability of
presentations in these patients it's
important that we do consider immune
deficiency and investigate either to
rule in or rule out
the primary immunodeficiency has been
studied for many many years and
classified and reclassified as we have
learned more about these diseases the IU
is is the International Union of amia
logical societies and within the IU is
the primary immunodeficiency expert
committee has published every year since
the 1990s a classification of immune
deficiencies and so as we've learned
more about these immunodeficiencies
we've moved from classifying them simply
into t-cell D cell or neutrophil
deficiencies into a broader
classification that has allowed us not
only to investigate these patients
better but also to provide good clinical
information the latest IU is
classification was published last year
in 2017 and classifies immune
deficiencies into nine different groups
the first one is a combined T and B cell
immune deficiency the severus form of
this category is skid or severe combined
immune deficiency which we will discuss
in a little more detail the second
category contains well-defined immune
deficiency syndrome an example is hyper
IgE syndrome or job syndrome
the third category predominantly
antibody deficiencies and the prototypic
antibody deficiency is x-linked a gamma
globulin emia that we will touch upon
the fourth category contains diseases of
immune dysregulation and an example here
is autoimmune lymphoproliferative
syndrome first category is congenital
defects of phagocytes so chronic
granulomatous disease which we discussed
a few minutes ago and will touch upon
under laboratory diagnosis diagnostic
strategies the sixth category defects in
intrinsic and innate immunity the
seventh Auto inflammatory disorders
viii has complement pathway deficiencies
and the ninth is phyno copies of primary
immunodeficiencies now this is a new
category and a very interesting one
where acquired autoantibodies can
disrupt the immune system and present as
a primary immunodeficiency or somatic
mutations may occur later in life
disrupting the immune system so it's
important to know that the ninth
category are not necessarily inherited
immune deficiencies but they present
like a genetic inherited immune
deficiency would so in this presentation
because the breadth of immune
deficiencies is very large and continues
to grow we will touch upon categories
one three and five under laboratory
diagnosis because as rare as they are
these are still the immune deficiencies
that are that are seen more commonly in
clinic so let's move on to laboratory
analysis of immune deficiency of course
laboratory analysis should be directed
by the clinical presentation and so it
is important to take a good clinical
history including a family history as I
had mentioned previously when the
clinical presentation is very obvious
such as a baby boy presenting with very
severe bacterial infections that may
guide the next step of laboratory
diagnosis in general an initial immune
assessment done in the laboratory would
include a complete blood count or a CBC
serum immunoglobulin levels lymphocyte
subsets which would include broadly the
T cells B cells natural killer cells
their percentages and absolute counts
and complement function complement
function tests test the integrity of the
entire complement pathway and it's known
as the CH 50 test so this cat this
category of test
as a broad overview of how the immune
system is working so what if all of
these parameters are normal and there is
still a suspicion for immune deficiency
it's possible to go further into
additional phenotyping of these immune
system cells and the functional analyses
some of the common tests are listed over
here we can look at t-cell proliferation
or the ability of t-cells to respond to
mitogenic or antigenic stimulation we
can further subset T and B cells look at
regulatory t-cell analyses particularly
in dysregulated conditions regulatory
t-cell analyses might be helpful this is
a small subset less than 10% of t-cells
in the immune system that regulates the
immune response of most of the other
cells and keeps them in check we can
also look at neutrophil oxidative burst
which is an important test for the
analysis of neutrophils function so
again this is not an exhaustive list by
any means these are some examples of
additional phenotype and function it's
important to understand that the initial
immune assessment has offered generally
by many clinical laboratories around the
country the additional phenotype and
functional testing may be offered in
some of the more specialized
laboratories that focus on immunological
testing and finally it's important to
follow up with genetic analyses because
at the end of the day once we do
identify an immune deficiency it's
important to know what the mutation is
is has is this inherited in some cases
it's possible to speak with the family
and determine if any other family
members might be at risk what is the
risk for this child if eventually has a
family to pass this mutation on to the
next generation so the genetic analysis
is a key component of the laboratory
analysis
immune deficiency however today we will
be focusing mostly on the immunological
phenotypic and functional analysis
so let's talk a little bit about the
disorders in Group one and I will focus
mostly on severe combined immune
deficiency otherwise known as skid so
scared is characterized by very severe
defects of both the cellular and the
humoral or antibody component of the
immune system the incidence is one in a
hundred thousand however if we look at
specific populations the incidence may
be higher so here's an example of the
Artemis gene that is involved in the
development of these immune cell
populations these mutations occur at a
much higher rate in Navajo Americans and
so while we might say the global
incidence is much lower when we do look
at specific populations particularly
populations where there may be contango
entity the incidence of some of these
mutations can be much higher so how does
skid patients present they are at very
high risk of serious infections
including opportunistic infections and
organisms of low pathogenicity that may
not affect people with a normal immune
system can cause serious infections in
these particular patients this failure
to thrive and unless it's recognized and
treated immediately these babies can
succumb to infection
so skid has been recognized as a disease
that if recognized early in life can be
treated and managed well and in many
cases give these babies a better chance
at a normal healthy life in the long run
so newborn screening for skid was
started in 2008 now a newborn screening
for a number of metabolic diseases has
been in place for many years and what is
used for these metabolic disorders is
the blood spot on the guthrie card a
field prick is done when a baby is born
and blood is spotted on to this country
card and used for newborn screening
tests so using this rationale in 2008 a
molecular test was developed to screen
for severe combined immune deficiency
now this cartoon gives an idea of how
this test is performed the dried blood
spot on the guthrie card is used a three
millimeter punch is taken out of the
card the DNA is extracted and the DNA is
examined for integrity by using PCR to
amplify beta-actin so this is a
housekeeping gene if the levels of
beta-actin are normal the quality of the
DNA is good
along with beta-actin a particular gene
that's involved in development of the
t-cell receptor is also amplified which
is an indication of the numbers of newly
developed alpha beta T cells now this
piece of DNA that's amplified is called
a t-cell receptor excision circle or
tracts and shown here is the formation
of this tract or T cell receptor
excision circle so when the TCR or the T
cell receptor forms in these t cells
that are within the thymus the T cells
germline DNA is rearranged using a
number of different genes that are
involved in the process
and as the TCR is rearranged a portion
of the DNA is pinched off and is left as
a circle of DNA within the cell it is
not used for the t-cell receptor it
simply is a circular piece of DNA called
a t-cell receptor excision circle that
is present in very high numbers in these
t cells that are exiting the thymus and
so shown in this cartoon is the germline
T cell receptor locus above on the
left-hand side you see the rearranged
TCR locus containing portions of the vdj
genes and on the right-hand side is a
circular piece of DNA called the track
or the T cell receptor excision circle
so PCR primers can be used to amplify
out this T cell receptor excision circle
and quantified and quantification of
these tracks tells us whether the baby
has produced sufficient numbers of alpha
beta T cells now this test can be done a
few days after birth giving us an
indication of whether the babies have
produced adequate numbers of T cells so
what is done with that information now
before we move into that the current
state of newborn screening for skid is
presented here this is from a paper 2017
newborn screening for skid was started
in 2008 by the state of Wisconsin and
then adapted by California and since
then has spread across the country and
so as you can see from this map almost
all of the states across the United
States have now implemented screening
for skid Louisiana and Indiana are
implementing it this year and this is a
huge achievement for progress into
understanding that these genetic defects
of the immune system
if recognized early on can give the
Bebe's a chance at a better life as they
are treated well within the first year
of life so what do we do following a
skid newborn screen for adequate numbers
of t-cells this is the state of
Colorado's workflow taking a look at the
blue box above when a baby is born and a
test for skid is run it's the number of
tracks or T cell receptor excision
circles is greater or equal to 40 which
is the state-established cutoff then the
baby's immune system is considered
normal we move down to the green square
no further testing is required if the
tracks are less than 40 then this is
considered an abnormal screen and the
test is repeated in duplicate if the
retest has a result of greater than 40
tracks then we consider this to be a
normal test to no further screening is
required however if the tracks are less
than 40 this is considered to be an
abnormal test but at that point it is
really important to look at the
beta-actin
level for the integrity of the DNA if
beta-actin is normal and tracks are low
this is considered to be an abnormal
screening for skid and the test is
repeated a second time to confirm as
shown in the red square if beta-actin is
low it indicates that perhaps the
quality of the sample was not optimal
and we could call this an inconclusive
test and go back and repeat the newborn
screening test again
[Music]
so if tracks if the track test is either
positive or inconclusive then we follow
it up by immunological testing the
testing involves a complete blood count
a TB NK panel which enumerates T cells B
cells and natural killer
cells from powerful blood and we also
look at naive and memory t-cells
percentages we'll discuss this in a
little more detail it's important to
note that not all fail skid screens are
indicators of severe combined immune
deficiency some of these screens may
fail because there is secondary
lymphopenia this is very common in
preterm babies sometimes due to
lymphatic loss following cardiothoracic
surgery or DiGeorge syndrome which is
really an issue with lack of development
or partial development of the thymus and
so t-cells are although they are present
they are unable to exit through the
thymus to the periphery as would
normally occur so it's important to note
that the skid screen that is low does
not always indicate severe combined
immune deficiency so let's take a look
at a very basic TBN case flow
phenotyping for skid now this is a flow
cytometry based assay performed in a
number of clinical labs it's the first
line for confirmation of a failed skid
screen and shown here are the data from
two flow cytometry tubes the top plots
are identified t-cell subsets the lower
plots identify TB and natural killer
cells so whole blood is stained with a
number of monoclonal antibodies that
specifically identify lymphocytes cd4
cd8 C D 3 T cells B cells using cd19 and
natural killer cells using a combination
of C D 16 and 56 and these are all
surface markers that are specific to
these cell subjects so if you take a
look at the first two plots on the Left
cd45 which is present on all nucleated
cells immune cells is used to
specifically identify lymphocyte
populations that are shown in red the
lymphocyte populations
can then be identified based on the
expression of CD 3 so that identifies T
cells and the T cells can be further
subsetted into cd4 and cd8 t-cells as
shown in the plot on the top row right
hand side similarly taking a look at the
plots on the bottom row on the right
hand side we can separate out non T
cells into cd19 B cells and natural
killer cells and so a very simple flow
cytometry as they using about 50
microliters of blood allows us to
enumerate all of these lymphoid cells in
the periphery and look at the numbers
and percentages so how does this help us
when we're faced with a newborn screen
skid result that is low or zero so this
is an example from a four day old baby
boy who had a trek level of zero and a
confirmatory flow cytometry test was run
as you can see in the plots there are
clearly populations that are missing so
for example the second plot from the
left is lacking cd3 cd4 and cd8 T cells
are completely absent cd19 b-cells are
present
natural killer cells are present in the
plot on the far right but it's very
evident that all P sub T cell subsets
are low and those numbers are shown in
red below in percentages so a typical
skid has absent or very low numbers of T
cells now here we're presenting them as
absolute counts so less than 300 cells
per microliter the other lab findings
are an absent or very low t-cell
function T cell function is commonly
measured by taking careful blood cells
and stimulating them with phyto
hemagglutinin which is a mitogen and
induces proliferation of T cell
so t-cell responses and truths kid is
very low less than 10% of the normal
control or normal range these babies may
have t-cells but they may be of maternal
origin and these maternal t-cells show a
memory phenotype which we will discuss a
little later it's important to note that
truce kid is an emergency because these
babies lack t-cells are very very highly
susceptible to viral infections fungal
infections and because they may be
exposed in their natural environment
within the family home they have to be
it has to be treated as an emergency and
the baby put in a situation where
they're shielded from infection and
evaluated for a bone-marrow transplant
as soon as possible
so for a typical skid that has been
identified by laboratory diagnosis and
genetic diagnosis in many cases a
bone-marrow transplant which effectively
replaces the immune system gives these
babies chance at a healthy life so these
this is just a list of genes implicated
and skated is by no means an exhaustive
list these are the most common genes
that are identified in skid as you can
see here in this table we classify them
broadly into t minus B plus skid which
indicates t-cells Rapson B cells are
present or skid in which both T and B
cells are absent shown on the right-hand
side
so some of the genes that are involved
here the T minus B plus kid as you can
see many of these genes are related to T
cell specific molecules or proteins for
instance the cd3 delta epsilon and zeta
are all involved with the cd3
glycoprotein that is specific to T cells
T and B T minus B minus skid the genes
involved here are more broadly and
involved in the development
meant of these lymphoid cells and so
their effect is broader on both
categories of T of T and B cells so we
had mentioned the utility of looking at
naive and memory T cell analysis and why
is it important in skid so naive and
memory T cells can be identified by
staining these cells by flow cytometry
with cd45 RA and ro cd45 RA and ro R
isoforms of the cd45 glycoprotein cd45
RA is present on naive t-cells cd45 ro
is present preferentially on memory T
cells and as you can see in this flow
cytometry plot on the left hand side it
is a continuum and they are not discrete
populations so there may be a
preponderance of naive T cells or
preponderance of memory T cells and
there are some in the middle that might
express both of these molecules what we
look at is the balance of these
populations as shown in the plot on the
left the pediatric populate cells tend
to have a much larger population of
naive T cells whereas the adult sample
has many more memory T cells and this is
what we would expect to see the newborn
baby we expect naive T cells to be close
to 90% so when we analyze naive and
memory T cells in a newborn baby and if
we find that the phenotype is skewed was
memory the following conditions can be
considered so leaky Skidz
where there may be a few T cells that
are in the periphery but because there
are only a few T cells they may undergo
what is called homeostatic proliferation
and they may respond to self antigens so
they increase in number develop a memory
phenotype and they may actually react
against self antigens Omen syndrome is
another case where there are reduced
numbers
eighty-three T cells but they present
with a memory phenotype and then finally
as we've discussed earlier maternal
engraftment or having some of the
mothers T cells in the baby system we
can certainly identify the spider memory
phenotype as well as genetic studies so
when analyzing a sample from a baby with
a failed skin screen it's important to
not only look at the TB and n K
populations but also the naive and
memory T cell populations and both of
these tests can be done very simply with
small amounts of peripheral blood
usually about 50 microliters for each of
these tests so let's move on to antibody
defects or group 3 of the classification
of primary immunodeficiencies when we
talk about antibody defects we usually
think about b cell development b cell
development in this cartoon takes there
are two stages to it we can look at the
stage of development that occurs in the
bone marrow and defects of maturation
that may that occur in the periphery so
development of B cells starts off from
the hemopoietic stem cell proceed
through the Proby stage the pre B stage
and the immature B cell which expresses
IgM on its surface before it exits to
the periphery in the periphery the
mature B cell undergoes encounter with
antigen it matures it can either take
the form of a plasma cell and secrete
antibody or become a long-lived memory B
cell and throughout this process one of
the important pieces is the ability of
the B cell to switch from producing IgM
to producing IgG or IgA or IgE and so
there are a number of genes involved
both in development and in maturation
and depending on where mutations occur
we may either not see B cells in the
periphery as would be the case with
defects in bruton's tyrosine kinase
for BTK which we will discuss in a
little more detail or defects and some
of the CVID related genes that occur in
the periphery can block the development
of memory b-cells populations and
antibody producing populations
so let's take a look at some of the
prototypic defects and b-cell
development now this is a case of a male
with recurrent infections had low or
absent immunoglobulins in the periphery
flow cytometry analysis was conducted on
a peripheral blood sample as we see in
the flow cytometry plot we can identify
lymphocytes in red on the upper left
hand side of the screen both cd4 shown
in blue and cd8 shown in red are present
however when we look at the plot below
we see adequate numbers of cd3 t-cells
in green but no b-cells so this is a
case of Britain's tyrosine kinase
mutations or BTK which lead to x-linked
a gamma globulin emia or xla so this is
again an x-linked conditions of presents
in boys or males there's a history of
recurrent infections predominantly of
the respiratory tract these patients
lack circulating b-cells very low
immunoglobulins of all classes and it's
possible to confirm the BTK protein
expression presence or absence by flow
cytometry it's also expressed in
monocytes and it's possible to pick it
up and monocytes
when b-cells are absent so in a patient
with BTK mutations b-cells are absent
monocytes do not express BTK protein
whereas the normal control will express
the protein in monocytes and b-cells and
of course sequencing is always
recommended to clinch the diagnosis so
bt k or x la is the prototypic antibody
deficiency where b-cells are absent in
the periphery so we'll move on then to
defect the maturation now in this case B
cells are present in the periphery they
can be detected by flow cytometry
however they're not
in the the proper way we would expect
them to function so one of the syndromes
that are often encountered with antibody
defects in maturation is the hyper IGM
syndrome clinical features here are
increased susceptibility to infections
in this case the patients have very high
levels or not sometimes normal levels by
GM but absence of IgG and IgA the most
common form of hyper IgM syndrome is
also excellent there are other
variations which are autosomal recessive
and these can present in either males or
females the hallmark of all of these
syndromes is the inability of b-cells to
switch from making IgM to making the
other classes of immunoglobulins and so
in this cartoon one of the major defects
we often find with hyper IgM syndrome is
cd40 ligand defect this is an x-linked
defect and interestingly the defect
occurs on the T cell not necessarily the
b-cell cd40 ligand on the T cell has to
interact with cd4 T on the B cell in
order for the B cell to switch from
making IgM to IgG IgA or IgE so cd40
ligand is an x-linked disease cd4 T may
be mutated causing hyper IgM syndrome as
can class switching recombinase and a
couple other genes along the signaling
pathway all of which are involved in the
switching of the B cell from making IgM
to making the other subclasses so we'll
take a look at some testing for hyper
IgM syndrome in general hyper IgM
syndrome due to any of these defects
cd40 ligand cd4 T or CS our class switch
recombination a present with a similar
clinical picture we have normal or
elevated IgM low IgG low IgA
and increase susceptibility to infection
these patients will have B cells in the
periphery as shown in the slow cytometry
plot if you look at the middle plot we
are identifying B cells here using cd20
and they are present in the lower plot
we can further subset B cells into one
switch B cells that Express IgD on their
surface and switch B cells that lose IgG
expression and make a GGA or e and they
all Express this molecule C d-27 so
they're all memory B cells some of which
make i GG a or E and some of which make
IgM so hyper IGM patients have increased
unsweet B cells that are making IgM or
in general they may just have low memory
B cells so again a very simple flow
assay using a small amount of blood can
tell us whether these memory populations
are present in adequate percentages or
not so to get a little more specific and
determine which of these defects effect
is causing hyper IGM syndrome in these
patients we can also analyze cd40 ligand
expression on t-cells now the important
thing with cd40 ligand is that it is
seen only on T cells that are activated
so looking at the flow cytometry data on
the Left we activate T cells in culture
for a short period of time about four
hours and then we identify cd4 T cells
shown in green by their expression of C
D 3 and their lack of expression of cd8
taking these cd4 T cells we then look
for specific expression of cd40 ligand
which is shown in these histogram plots
below the top one shows an isotype
control which doesn't show specific
training for cd40 ligand the middle one
is specific for cd40 ligand and most
importantly
we use an activation marker CD 69 to
indicate that the t-cells have activated
now this is important because if the
t-cells have not activated well in this
test and cd40 ligand expression is
absent the test result is inconclusive
we need to know that the cells have been
activated and do express cd40 ligand so
how are these results look in a patient
with cd40 ligand mutations shown here in
red is a schematic of a male child
elevated IgM low IgG low IgA
opportunistic infections and as we see
here there is no cd40 ligand expression
shown by this red histogram in the
presence of good activation and CD 69
expression as this is an x-linked
disorder it's important to also analyze
the mother sample and as shown in green
the mother has two peaks one that is
defective low no expression of cd40
ligand corresponding to the patient and
one that is normal corresponding to the
healthy control sample and this is an
important piece of information as an
x-linked disorder the mother has one
normal x chromosome and one abnormal and
male child has a 50/50 chance of
inheriting either the mutated X
chromosome or the normal X chromosome so
being able to analyze the mother sample
and knowing that there is a carrier
state allows advising the family in
terms of the impact of these genetics on
perhaps any other children daughters may
have a chance of being a carrier for
instance so we'll move on to group 5 and
talk a little bit about congenital
defects of phagocytes so again with
neutrophils we can consider defects of
development that can be intrinsic
genetically acquired or
acquired defects that are due to say
drug-induced neutropenia defects of
function can affect multiple functions
of the neutrophils either their
adherence to the endothelium their
ability to move or chemotaxis their
ability to produce good reactive oxygen
intermediates that are responsible for
bacterial clearance or some of the extra
cellular mechanisms that they use to
combat infection now for the purpose of
this talk we will only focus on a couple
of the defects of function that are more
commonly seen in the clinic we'll talk a
little bit about defects of neutrophil
adherence and defects of neutrophil
oxidative burst
so just to go over defect to neutrophil
function this cartoon taken from a paper
published several years ago nicely
illustrates the functionality of
neutrophils neutrophils
found in the bloodstream tend to roll
along until they receive a stimulus
perhaps from an infection at which point
they will arrest on the endothelium due
to the expression of surface molecules
called integrants once they arrest on
the endothelium they undergo something
called IP decease where they squeeze
through the endothelium to get into the
tissue spaces by the effect of
chemotaxis
which is their ability to move towards a
chemical stimulus they move towards the
site of infection the phagocytose the
organisms and then they produce reactive
oxygen intermediates to clear the
infection so along the way a number of
genes are involved in this process as
are illustrated in this cartoon and we
will talk a little bit about the
integrant and mutations in these
integrants that are important for
adherence can lead to leukocyte adhesion
defect or la d la d one two and three we
will discuss led1 and the genes involved
in the oxidative burst or respiratory
burst that mutations in these genes can
lead to chronic granulomatous disease so
we'll discuss the laboratory diagnosis
for a couple of these conditions the
leucocyte addition defect this these
mutations are characterized by recurrent
severe infections with bacteria or fungi
one of the hallmarks of la D is delayed
separation of the umbilical part in
babies and this is important to note
because separation of the umbilical cord
is a process of inflammation you we
require neutrophils to migrate to the
site and by the process of an
inflammatory reaction the cord separates
in the case of laad the neutrophils can
get to where they have to go and so the
umbilical card separation is
significantly delayed also significant
is the absence of paths at the site of
infection again because neutrophils are
unable to migrate to that site so
mutations in the cd18 gene affect
expression of the integrin CD 11 a B and
C these integrins are present on the
surface of the neutrophil and their
expression and function is important for
neutrophils to tether to the endothelium
and then to get into the tissue spaces
to the site of infection
so how do we diagnose la t1 this is done
again by a very simple flow cytometry a
say we take whole blood as shown here we
choose to analyze just the neutrophils
as shown in red on the top left and then
the specific expression of the integrin
CD 11 a CD 11 B and C D 11 C as shown in
the histograms below is examined it's
important to note that CD 18 or the beta
chain associates which with each of
these molecules so that they are
expressed on the surface adequately we
measures off all four of them CD 11 a b
c and c d 18 so let's take a look at an
L ad patient now this patient underwent
bone marrow transplant and as we can see
here in the flow cytometry plot the
expression of CD 11 a CD 18 CD 11 B and
C D 11 C all show two peaks the first
peak is very similar to the ISO type
control indicating that there is no
expression of the integrins the second
peak which is much smaller is
illustrative of the newly engrafted bone
marrow and the fact that normal
neutrophils are now developing that
express these integrins although they're
in much lower numbers this assay can be
used to monitor the patient over time
and determine the extent of Kaymer ism
of the normal engrafted bone marrow and
the defective population so finally
we'll take a look at neutrophil
oxidative burst now neutrophil oxidative
burst is the tail end of the neutrophil
physiological process and clearance of
infection so at the end of this process
the neutrophils engulf the invading
organism under these reactive oxygen
intermediates to clear infection so the
way this occurs
is through the NADPH complex the NADPH
complex is composed of two protein
subunits that are present within the
cell membrane GP 22 Fox and GP 91 Fox in
the presence of infection a number of
cytosolic proteins are recruited to the
membrane GP 47 67 GP 40 Fox and rag2 and
together they form the NADPH complex
that allows the transport the electron
transport chain to then release reactive
oxygen intermediates that are mediators
of antimicrobial activity so mutations
that any of these proteins can lead to
chronic granulomatous disease and the
incidence is shown in this table the GP
91 fox of the major subunit in the
membrane that's encoded by the gene CY
BD is inherited through an x-linked
mechanism and mutations in this gene
account for about two-thirds of the
incidents of chronic granulomatous
disease that is seen in the United
States so this particular disease the
x-linked form can present in baby boys
with very severe infections very classic
presentation however autosomal recessive
mutations can occur in most of the other
subunits causing perhaps a milder
disease just just depends on the extent
to which oxidative burst is affected
now these mutations the incidence again
is shown in this table P 47 20 percent P
22 and 67 at 5% and P 40 to date one
case has been reported so to some extent
all of these jeans they are mutations
can be inherited in an autosomal
recessive manner causing perhaps miler
disease and can be seen in
males or females so the clinical
presentation of x-linked chronic
granulomatous disease is in males they
present with severe bacterial and fungal
infections within the first two years of
life bacterial abscesses very severe
skin and gastrointestinal tract
infections the autosomal recessive form
is males or females they may have milder
infections really depending on the
extent of the oxidative burst activity
and finally it's important to note that
with the x-linked disease females are
carriers and they may be asymptomatic
all those newer publications indicate
that they may present with some
autoimmune manifestations
so the laboratory diagnosis of CJD is
again done in a number of labs around
the country and is done with a fairly
simple test in whole blood so in this
assay whole blood is stimulated with PMA
and these cells are preloaded with a dye
called dihydrate amine one two three now
this dye once the loaded into the
neutrophils and the neutrophils are
stimulated can fluoresce very brightly
because it gets oxidized by the reactive
oxygen intermediates so shown in this
flow plot on the left hand side are
neutrophils identified by the scatter
gate the second plot shows us the
neutrophils with no dye the middle plot
is DHR loaded into the neutrophils
showing baseline fluorescence and
finally the plot on the far right shows
us the fluorescence of DHR once the
cells are stimulated and as you can see
the fluorescence is off scale here
because it is so bright
following stimulation of normal
neutrophils so we calculate an index
value that is based on the fluorescence
of the stimulated cells divided by the
fluorescence
of the unstimulated cells and each lab
establishes their own index value in our
lab it is greater than 30 so an index
value of greater than 30 indicates a
normal oxidative burst if it's less than
that then this is indicated of a defect
in oxidative burst and needs to be
investigated further so let's take a
look at some plots published in 2017 for
chronic granulomatous disease on the
left hand side we see the top histograms
showing a normal response the resting
cells show very little activity the
simulated cells show a nice peak once
oxidative burst occurs x-linked chronic
granulomatous disease in the middle from
a baby boy show a complete lack of
oxidative burst the carriers phenotype
is shown in the plots below so the plot
on the left-hand side shows no activity
and then there are two peaks following
stimulation indicating an abnormal at a
normal neutrophil population autosomal
recessive patients are rather more
difficult to diagnose simply because
there's more variation in their
oxidative burst result so shown here on
the right hand side are some plots from
autosomal recessive CJD patients one of
the characteristics is a rather broad
peak shown in the top plots on the right
hand side following stimulation so
instead of seeing a nice sharp peak upon
stimulation these patients may show a
rather broader flatter peak indicating
perhaps compromised oxidative burst it's
also interesting to note that one of the
patients in this publication showed no
oxidative burst whatsoever but were
later confirmed to be autosomal
recessive when you look at the data they
look like a classic x-linked CJD so
again it emphasizes that while the
protein
and functional studies are important
genetic sequencing is always important
to confirm the diagnosis of primary
immunodeficiency so I'd like to leave
you with some final thoughts this is a
very extensive topic and I have covered
a high level of primary
immunodeficiencies and gone over some of
the more commonly used diagnostic
testing diagnosis of primary
immunodeficiencies does pose challenges
both to the physician and laboratory
it may not follow a linear path we may
not be able to just go from t BN k
analyses to b cell phenotype or t cell
phenotype and function these immune
deficiencies may present in a very
complex way making it difficult to
choose any one clinical test for an
obvious clinical presentation like
chronic granulomatous disease it may be
easy enough to take the clinical
presentation and go straight away to
neutrophil oxidative burst laboratory
analysis the phenotype and function may
be followed by genetic analysis when
required and finally I'd like to leave
you with the thought that diagnosis of
immune deficiency can be complicated
because it may be influenced by other
factors for the types of infections that
the patient has may in turn impact
immune function the genetics the
epigenetics the environment what are
they exposed to so it's very important
to get a good combination of clinical
history family history clinical
examination and careful laboratory
evaluation to reach a diagnosis I would
like to acknowledge both of the
institutions that I have worked at in
the past ten years the Children's
Hospital Colorado where I am currently
with the Department of Pathology
laboratory medicine flow cytometry lab
as well as the section of clinical
immunology and allergy within the
department of pediatrics
and at national Jewish Health where I
was previously with the advanced
diagnostics immunology and flow
cytometry lab and the division of
clinical immunology and Allergy
Department of Pediatrics as my
collaborators and of course a lot of
what I have discussed today would not be
possible without the collaboration with
the physicians and particularly the
patients at both of these institutions
much of what we have developed over the
years is all because of patients coming
in with these unusual presentations and
requiring us to think beyond standard
immunological testing and think about
how best to go beyond that to more
extensive phenotyping and function so
thank you very much for listening in and
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you dr. night for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left to your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is if
adequate numbers of t-cells are detected
by flow cytometry in a patient's
peripheral blood sample does it rule out
immune deficiency Thank You Alexis that
is a really important question one of
our the first line of diagnosis
laboratory diagnostic tests is the TB NK
analysis which detects T cells B cells
and NK cells as we've seen in the
presentation when we take the example of
a failed treck screen and analyze a baby
sample as follow-up we may actually
detect T cells so does it necessarily
rule out immune deficiency not
necessarily because these T cells could
be a maternal origin they could be
memory t-cells they could be
functionally impaired some of the genes
involved in T cell development do not
impact T cell development but impact T
cell function so when we are
suspecting immune-deficiency very
strongly from a clinical perspective and
even if we do detect adequate numbers of
t-cells if the suspicion is high enough
we should move on to further phenotyping
them to see if they are naive or memory
or subsets of memory t-cells and are
they functional if we stimulate them
will they proliferate in the laboratory
setting so follow-up testing is still
very important
now dr. Knight our next question is a
failed newborn screen for skin
necessarily indicative of a genetic
defect so a failed newborn screen for
skin indicates that there are low
numbers of t-cells it is important to
follow up with flow cytometry to
determine if they truly are low numbers
of t-cells it's not always necessary
that these babies that fail the skin
screen have a genetic defect sometimes
it could be due to loss of lymph fluid
lymphatic leakage so the T cells are not
circulating in the periphery but they
are being generated in normal numbers a
failed skid screen may be commonly seen
in premature babies so it's important to
understand the other clinical features
before going on to genetics in case of a
premature baby testing may be warranted
in a few weeks to allow for the immune
system to mature and then repeat the
test again again another example that we
touched upon is the DiGeorge syndrome
where the thymus may not have developed
adequately or is absent so again t-cells
are being produced normally this is not
a genetic defect of t-cell development
but it is instead a problem with the
thymus so not all failed skin screens
necessarily indicate a genetic defect
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
when you do an immune assessment of a
patient you mentioned running CBC
immunoglobulin and a complement in
addition to the T and B cell uation can
you comment on whether you order all of
test at the same time or if results are
some dictate for the testing that's a
great question Alexis and yes so we
normally go with an initial screen a
complete blood cell count is almost
routine when you're examining a patient
with immune deficiency just to get a
sense of numbers of lymphocytes
monocytes and so on again serum
immunoglobulins is a good indicator but
again we often go with the clinical
picture now if the patient has severe
infection say with capsulated bacterial
pneumococcal infections we might lean
more towards looking at the
immunoglobulins and complement because
both of those components are really
important for protection against
capsulated bacteria if the patient has
say severe fungal infections or viral
infections we might lean more towards
analyzing the t cell arm of the immune
system so while this broad screen is
helpful I think in many cases in the I
would say the community setting when
you're thinking about immune deficiency
a CBC immunoglobulins TB NK at the very
least are very useful to get a global
assessment of the immune system if
there's a strong suspicion or clinical
history of encapsulated bacterial
infections and complement testing could
be added in since it is a critical
component
thank you dr. nate do you have any final
comments for audience I would just like
to say that it's been a pleasure of
developing and putting this webinar
together and thank you to both lab roots
and binding site for hosting it this
primary immunodeficiency I would say is
an area that is continually growing new
defects are continuously being
identified the laboratory plays a really
important role in working
collaboratively with the physician
in helping to analyze diagnose and
follow these patients so again thank you
fall for listening in and I hope that
you have found this webinar useful thank
you again dr. night for your time today
and your tan research we would also like
to think levers and our sponsor binding
site for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions question we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through May of 2019 leverage
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye